nous comptons une france fidèle à son
histoire une france compétitive il
france protéger d'une france innovante
devons vaincre le chômage de masse
gagner la guerre contre le terrorisme
prend du pouvoir d'achat aux français
assurer l'équité entre tous les
territoires réconcilier les français
avec les institutions répondre au défi
démographique et aux enjeux de cohésion
nationale
mes chers compatriotes les 11 et 18 juin
prochain vous allez choisir vos députés
ce sont eux qui au parlement vont fixer
le cadre général des grandes
orientations à venir pour notre pays
nous avons un projet nous sommes prêts à
le mettre en oeuvre un projet
d'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat avec
la défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires nous baisserons l'impôt
sur le revenu de 10 % un projet de refus
de l'augmentation spectaculaire de la
csg qui va impacter les retraités les
fonctionnaires les professionnels
libéraux et qui va en réalité un pacte
et toute la société française
nous sommes prêts également parce que
notre projet veut réarmer l'état
restaurer son autorité
nous sommes favorables au rétablissement
des peines planchers nous sommes
favorables
à une négociation de chaque gamme pour
protéger nos frontières et éviter un
chaos migratoires que nous ne pouvons
pas accueillir
nous avons une équipe rassemblée soudée
nous avons un renouvellement forts de
nos candidats deux jeunes hommes et
femmes qui incarnent une génération qui
se lève qui demande un espoir
ils sont là au rendez vous ils sont à
vos côtés les 11 et 18 juin prochains
donnant une majorité pour la franche
pour que vive la république
et pour que vive la france
[Musique]